And, everybody, welcome to another call, where I do the best to answer your questions.
Remember to look at the members to meet for any new information if there is any new announcements,
and that's where you can post your questions as well, but feel free to chat in any questions
along the way.
Let's get started with the questions that were submitted.
This question, how long does it take to detox the toxins out of my body?
I'm talking about the toxins that showed up the toxic detox test.
So regardless of what toxins you have, whether it's a chemical toxicity from the tech test
that's shown on that, or if it's a heavy metal toxicity, or if it's a mycotoxin, there's
different factors that are involved.
The first rule in detoxification is that if your level of toxic exposure is exceeding your
rate or your ability to get rid of that toxic exposure, then you're going to become toxic.
So, yes, one of the factors in your ability to get rid of something is your ability to mitigate
exposure to something, and it isn't necessarily that one thing, let's say if I have high levels
of 2, 4D, which is herbicide, and that would show up in the toxic detox test.
So let's pretend that was really high levels of that, and I had some elimination of mycotoxins,
and I started to do some detoxing, maybe I started to use some sort of key later, some sort
of binder.
I'm doing some things to support my liver, I'm doing coffee edamins, I'm doing the castoral
packs, or just heaty packs over my liver, I'm taking deadlion root and milk thistle and
supporting liver detox pathways, et cetera, et cetera.
If you're currently exposed to other toxins, not even the ones that were elevated, let's
say you've reduced your, let's use the 2, 4D as an example, that's an herbicide, let's
say, oh, well, we were herbicide on our lawn, and I was going to this park which had beautiful
grass, most likely used an herbicide on it, and I was laying down in the grass because
I just love to do that, let's say my exposure to 2, 4D was high, thereby giving me elevated
2, 4D levels of the toxic detox test, let's say I've stopped that, but now I'm maybe exposed
to something else, I don't know, let's say you're eating more, you know, panfish because
it's summertime when you like to fish, and it has high levels of mercury.
So anything that's going to put a burden on your liver is going to hinder any detoxification.
The detox pathways, typically you're pan 1 and your cytochrome p450 pathways, your net
pathways and your glutathione pathways that are responsible for getting rid of toxins that
are circulating forever.
You're exposed to something, either you breathe it in, you ingest it and you absorb it or
you inject it by going to get it in a vaccine or something like that, it's in your system and
it's circulating in your blood, it's going to go through the liver and your liver is going
to get rid of a lot of it, but your liver can become overwhelmed and then literally your
liver is saying no vacancy, so it circulates around in your blood again and it's going through
your liver again.
If your liver is currently occupied, those liver detox pathways are working overtime because
of your exposure being so high or because of damaged liver from past, I used to drink a lot
or whatever, however you damaged your liver or I have genetically poor detox pathways, my
rate of detoxification may be slowed.
If my rate of detoxification is slow, whatever is currently circulating in my blood may not
be able to exit via the liver, what's not going to exit any other way unless you're going
to do it in the soda and you're out sweating and whatever, so it's going to be pushed into
the tissues and it can be pushed into the cells, so that is technically my level of toxicity
is what is in my tissues, what is in my cells, now we can measure that, get it's still
not a perfect measurement, but we can measure it with a urine test to see where you're at,
at least shows us what you're excreting and if you're excreting at a high levels of
keep you door example of 2, 4D, that says that you probably are exposed to a lot of that,
so helping your body get rid of that is necessary.
So using key laders, using binders, supporting liver detox pathways, doing everything that
is in that course of the 7 phases of detox to make sure I'm getting out what's on the inside
is necessary.
Now I may have limitations to my liver's ability to get rid of things due to some of the things
that I mentioned, maybe it's genetic issues, maybe it's previous damage to my liver, maybe
I am metastasis to my liver, maybe I have other issues with my liver, so I'm going to
have, you know, an inherent, you know, slower rate of detoxification, that's very common
in people that have toxicity issues, so let's say we take that into account, how fast
to answer this question, it's very difficult to answer, obviously, how fast can I get rid
of these toxins, it depends on the accumulation of what you're doing to help your liver get rid
of these things, plus accumulation of what you're doing to limit your exposure to all toxins,
not just the one that was elevated in some test, all toxins and is the answer, so in factoring
the inherent issues that a person may have with their liver, I've said this multiple times
that say two people living in the same household, one shows elevated toxins, let's pretend
if we could have a scenario like this which is impossible, that they were both exposed to
the exact same number of toxins, same percentage of toxins per body weight, one has toxicity
issues, one doesn't, the factors of that would be the limited factors of the liver's ability
to detox in the rate of detoxification, which can be genetic, so a person can genetically
have slow detoxification pathways and they just accumulate poisons more easily because they're
a slower detoxer, and we see that a lot with cancer patients, these people with cancer,
people with toxicity issues have genetically just slower detoxification pathways, they're
not able to get rid of things that they otherwise would want to get rid of, and that that
could accumulate in the body because all sorts of problems, so sorry, but not an easy way
to answer the question, bottom line it can take however long it needs to take, and running
the test again, that would be a good question, when should I run the test again?
I always say six months because it really takes that much time to get rid of stuff, and don't
be surprised if you ran the toxicity test again, and let's say I was elevated in 2, 4,
D, 6 months ago, and now that is with the normal levels, but something else is now elevated.
Welcome to the world of worldly poisons that we live in, to do our best to try to keep
away from these things, but they're sprayed in everywhere, it's sprayed in the skies, it's
sprayed on everything, it's in all our food sources, even if it's organic, it's still cross-contaminated,
it's everywhere, these poisons are everywhere, we need to support detoxification all the time,
that's why people will ask me all the time, what's a good detox to do? Life is a good detox, you need to
be supporting your seven phase of detox all that time, there's not just such a thing as I'm going to
do this detox, and then I'm going to be done, you're constantly supporting vacation, that's the only way
to live, so the more you can do that, the benefit of running a test like this and seeing positive results
gives you clues that I have issues with my detoxification pathways, so I need to support it even more,
so lots of times when people run a test, toxicity tests, and they're all clean, that's really a good
doesn't mean that they necessarily lived a cleaner life than another person, but they just have a
really healthy liver, so they're just getting rid of this stuff quite quickly, so that's a good thing,
but that's a rare thing too, hope that helps, next question, I've hearing a lot about parasite
cleanses, is this something necessary to do, and also would it be something that my husband and kids
should do also, what do you recommend? Well, similar to supporting detoxification, I would have a
similar answer to supporting pathogens, except that, you know, pathogens, yes, they're a ubiquitous
meeting, they're everywhere, and yes, we are picking up parasites, especially if you have animals,
if you have pets, cats, dogs, that's really where you're picking up 90% of your parasites, not necessarily
dietary, now understand how do parasites get into us, so most the time parasites come into our body
orally, yes, you could have hookworms, especially down south, if you're walking around in the grass,
and hookworms are very covered to get into your skin, that's how that's why they're named that way,
and they bury, burrow into your skin and get into your blood that way, but most pathogens, most
parasites are ingested, yes, you could get viruses and bacteria through the nasal cavity and through the
lungs, but we're talking about parasites here, most of those are going to be ingested, understand
why do people get parasites anyhow? Well, the number one reason why we get parasites, not talking
about source, but the number one reason why we get parasites is because we have a decreased hydrochloric
acid in the stomach, so hypochloridria is the number one reason why we get parasites, why do you say
that? Because if we had healthy stomach acids, so our pH of our stomach was at 1.5 to 2.5
and all times, and we, our dog licked our face and we got eggs of parasites because of the dog
had parasites, we get that in our mouth and we swallow that, or we eat sushi and we get parasites
through raw fishers, whatever oral source or through food that even other pathogens and bacteria
through food, let's say we were exposed, went to a restaurant and person had unclean hands,
it was unclean kitchen, and we have bacteria in the kitchen and we get that in our food and we eat
the food, now we got food poisoning. The number one way to prevent against food poisoning and any
oral source of parasites or bacteria is to have healthy HCl in your stomach. If you have healthy HCl
in your stomach, 99% of things are going to survive that, so bacteria will be killed, parasites,
eggs will be killed by the HCl in the stomach, and then we never get parasites. But the problem is
the number one issue in all the world, health wise, probably is hypochloridria, decreased stomach acid,
and why is that? Because we're exposed to chemicals, diets, food colorings,
additives, flavorings, pesticides, herbicides, you name it, they damage the
parietal cells of the stomach, that's the cell in the stomach that makes HCl, then we end up with
hypochloridria and it's a whole cascade of issues. We have an increased risk of food issues,
bacteria, viruses, other pathogens like parasites coming through food, coming through the oral cavity,
into the stomach that survives the stomach because the pH of the stomach is now 4.0 or something,
goes into the smell and test it and starts growing and that's where we get infections.
So our oral source of defense against pathogens is HCl. That's why I literally have
recommended for every single patient to be taking an HCl product. So clear digests, HCl's I'm,
that is your best thing to take to prevent pathogens.
Number two, let's say we already have pathogens, we already have parasites. What if I already
have them? I mean, I just started taking that, if I start taking HCl today and I already have parasites
in my intestinal tract or in my liver, is that going to help kill that? No, now we have to talk about
parasite cleanses. So what are parasite cleanses? Well, parasite cleanses, my definition, is simply taking
anti-parasitic nutrition. So there's different anti-parasitic nutrition that can be better for certain
types of parasites, quote, pathogens than others. So let's say I have Hpylori. The number one,
it's not a parasite, that's a bacteria, but that's the number one pathogen that one would have
because of hypochloridria, again, would be garlic, oregano, burberry, those would be your biggest
choices for that. A bacterial infection that it got, you could say the same thing,
burberry, oregano, garlic. How about parasites? Well, there's a whole bunch of different herbs that can
be good for parasites, garlic, and burberry, and oregano can be good for parasites as well, but a whole
bunch of other things, cloves, and we have a product called ParaClear. We also have some products that
you have to take like four different supplements to do this cleanse. I've just in favor of taking less
stuff. So I like ParaClear simply because, if you looked at the bottle, it's got, it really covers a
broad spectrum of parasites. I mean, ParaClear could be greatly used for Hpylori as well. So I like
ParaClear because it's in one bottle. Now, because there's so much in it, you might have to take
more pills than cells, but it's easier to take because you're just taking out one bottle instead of
remember to take two in a pair of one, two in a pair of two, two in a pair of three, you know,
it's just, it's a simpler. So can anybody do ParaClear? Yes, the only caveat to doing these things,
though, is these things are immune stimulators. So if a person has a no autoimmune disease,
they could feel worse doing a parasite cleanse because most ParaClear, all ParaClear
cleansing are going to have immune stimulators in them. So learn more about that on the autoimmune
course. I won't go into that. I've talked about that many times, but if you have a no autoimmune
disorder and you're suffering from that autoimmune disorder, and doing a parasite cleanse thinking
that you're going to get better, can actually make you worse because you're stimulating your immune system,
you're going to destroy that which you have antibodies against, which is your own self tissue.
I go into that ad nausea on the autoimmune course. So if you want to learn more about that,
you can. But if you don't think you have an autoimmune disease that I'm thinking my husband and my
kids may have parasites using ParaClear can be a good thing to do. Now, when I've tested people,
four parasites on ParaClear and they show positive for parasites, you tend to have to take like
six to nine to those a day. I'm not even able to take 12 to 15 a day for a short period of time.
But just on a regular basis, taking three to six of them for a week may be perfectly fine to knock
something out. So the product is ParaClear. It's a cutters clinic product. Next question.
I currently put equal parts, Epsom salts, and filtered water into a spray bottle,
then spray it on my torso and legs after a sun, when my pores are open. Is this a good way to
supplement magnesium or am I missing out on other vital, on another vital form? Well, Epsom salts
is a magnesium salt. Now, there has been other topical magnesiums that we've used in the past.
There's a magnesium oil that you could get as a spray. I think it's an olive oil or some base.
And for if that was really popular and it's making it come back, sometimes these supplement things
have trends and it's trending more. The magnesium oil is trending more. But it isn't magnesium salt
that when it gets on your skin, do you absorb some? Yes. Do you absorb some Epsom salts when you
take an Epsom salt back? Yes, you do. Do you absorb a lot? No, not really. You don't really absorb
a lot through your skin. The negative of the oils, or doing what you're doing, dissolving the salt
in a water and spray it on, it can leave a salty residue on your skin and you notice that. And especially
with the oil, people who used to notice like a white residue that was left. That's just the magnesium
salt that's left. I really don't think you're absorbing a lot. Of course, you're not paying a lot
for the Epsom salts filtered water. So I don't say negative to that. But the magnesium oils that are
now making it come back trend wise to use as a topical source of magnesium. For the cost of it,
just take some magnesium. Magnesia was a fairly inexpensive supplement to take. Why try to absorb it
through your skin when you could just just it absorbs quite well in your gut. So now I understand
this is an expensive way to do it. I think the oil is kind of silly. People who say, well, it's better
because my child won't take a pill. Well, there's magnesium powders that are you know, flavored with
natural, you know, good, natural flavor that is that kids will drink. I don't see really a benefit
of the oil. I don't see a benefit of the topical. I just don't know how much a person is really absorbing.
So I don't, I don't, I'm not a big fan of that. Next question. I purchased the rebuilder. So
understand for those who don't know, the rebuilder is a medical tool, which is this kind of a
type of an electric stem that stimulates at the very specific frequency to stimulate neurogenesis,
neurohealing. And it's approved by the FDA. It's a nice tool. It's worked quite well over the years.
It's been out for probably 15 years now. I purchased the rebuilder and I'm not sure I've
used it correctly. I have water in both sides of a divided container. That's correct. I insert one
of the pads. They're the rubber pads on each side and turn on the device with having one foot
in each side of the container. I'm afraid to turn it up too high. How do I know if the nerves are
being properly, properly stimulated? I also run it with my hands on either side. My neuropathy has
gotten quite bad. So how high you turn it up is how is to your ability to tolerate it within reason.
I know some guys are like, I just take it and give you all you can. You know, more the better. You
do reach a limit. The more, you know, the more you do, it's not necessarily better. But you need
to feel a very strong tingle. So you want to feel a very strong tingle, but not uncomfortable.
That's the rule of the game. Nice strong tingle, but not so strong that it's like this is hurts.
This is uncomfortable. It's recommended by the company that you do it 30 minutes a day.
However, I know the owner of the company. I've been to his seminars. I've spoken to him
personally and really all the research shows you really 15 minutes a day or if you did 15 minutes
twice a day, you'd actually do better than 30 minutes one today. What about the neuropathy? What if it's
getting worse? You just need to keep doing it neuropathy. So I do have a video. If you go to our blog
post on neuropathy, I have several, several blog posts on neuropathy. And I think I actually have
this video on the store site for the rebuild or two where I talk about efferent versus afferent
nerves. I think that's a beneficial. It's a little heady, but it's beneficial to understand the pathways
because when you understand how your body is rebuilding the nerves, when you have neuropathy,
you do have to kind of go through sometimes a worsening before it gets better. So if your neuropathy
has gotten so bad where you have no feeling in your feet, we have a number of people who will buy
the rebuilder that aren't necessarily patients that they lost the feeling to their feet and understand
the diabetic neuropathy is very common. Now this person who asked this question may be suffering
from diabetic neuropathy or a combination thereof with chemotherapy and new neuropathy. But either way,
high blood sugars or chemotherapy can can destroy the peripheral nerves. And then those nerves
have to rebuild. Now the large diameter afference, that's the technical name for the first nerve
that's destroyed, has to rebuild the large diameter afference, carry pain and tingling back to
the brain. So when you're re-stimulating those, you may experience an increase in pain and tingling.
Keep doing it. If that will start to calm down and you'll start to get your feeling back. So
watch, try to watch that video. I know I think I have some other videos of just answering questions
on neuropathy. But watch the video where I live talking about afferent versus efferent neural pathways.
And I think that will help. Don't give up. This is the best way. The rebuilder is the best way
to help a person with their, with their opathy, just bar none. Okay, next question.
I'm going off of the Kisquale prescription and starting mistletoe and B-17. The man did help
the brass get better and color back. So I know the hormone purpose of it helped in one way.
The other I'm going off of it, should I start dim or another supplement to stop the hormonal feeding.
Okay, so I think there's a misunderstanding of what Kisquale does because
if you went and looked up Kisquale, it is not an aroma taste inhibitor. So it is for
her to positive breast cancer. But it blocks a different pathway. What's called the CDK pathway.
So it's called a CDK inhibitor. It's not an aroma taste inhibitor. So it's, you know,
most people that are on Kisquale are also on an aroma taste inhibitor. And most people that are
following their oncologists' suggestions are taking a medically prescribed aroma taste inhibitor.
Not dim or aroma clear or something. They're taking the drug. That is the aroma taste inhibitor.
So if let's say I was on dim or some natural aroma taste inhibitor,
which again is going to do equally to what the drug will just shut off all astrogens.
And then I was going to do Kisquale. I wouldn't go off the aroma taste inhibitor either the drug
or dim because Kisquale isn't taking the place of a natural or a medically prescribed aroma taste
inhibitor. So the answer to the question, yes, I would go back on dim if that's what you were using
for your aroma taste inhibite. Definitely, I would go back on that. Next question. Is a raw food
diet good for a cancer patient? I've seen several Instagram posts about this.
We've talked about this a lot in the past. And the number one rule is that
be careful what you see on Instagram or Facebook, especially when they're making blanket statements
like every cancer patient should do this. Now there are some general rules of thumb that every
cancer patient should start limiting their sugar intake because glucose is going to be a feeder
of any cancer or of any cell. But a raw food diet craze. Again, these things kind of go in trends,
right? So the trend of a raw food diet for every cancer patient, you know, I hear that from
Chris beat cancer or something like that. Well, Chris did Chris work did use a raw food diet for his
colon cancer to my understanding. I hope I'm not misquoting him. And it really helped him. I'm
sure that's not the only thing he did, but he was also in his 20s when he had colon cancer.
I understand a raw food diet, even if you're juiced, you still have it's still difficult to digest.
So for instance, if we have a patient with gut problems, let's say they don't have cancer at all,
they come to us with serious gut problems, a lot of food allergies and such.
We put them on more of what's called a gaps diet. A gaps diet as you start off with bone broth,
I would not recommend that for cancer patients to high in glutamate. Then you go to soups.
And you're at a very anti-inflammatory diet that has food that is soft and easily digestible because
it's broken down. And those people with serious gut problems would probably never go on a raw food
diet. They would stay away from raw food. It's too difficult to digest. And they have too high
fiber content, especially if they have SIBO to cause all sorts of other gut issues.
So my answer to this is no absolutely not a raw food diet is not good for any cancer patient.
Some cancer patients, yes, but certainly anybody that's over 40 years old maybe,
you're going to have much more typical time digested a raw food diet. They already probably have
a deficiency in HCL and your stomach. Like we talked about in the previous question,
we have a deficiency in digestive enzymes. Your pain grease has already been taxed and you're trying
to know what a put that food in your gut that is going to be very difficult to digest and could cause
other things. And if you have inflammation in the gut, let's say if you have breast cancer and
now you're doing something that's causing more inflammation in the gut, you're making it much
more difficult for your immune system to kill the breast cancer. So that's you'd have to be careful
of those kind of things. Do not look at Instagram and say, oh, that makes sense because that healed
this person. So then you look at the comments and you got 50 people that said, yeah, I healed myself
with raw food diet. You don't know their age when they did that. You have no idea the rest of their
history. You have no idea whether it's just a person who posted that video's friends who are making
those comments. So they get more likes and views on this. They have no idea how
getting those things help boost that Instagram post and help that person financially. You're just
going to be really, really careful of that. That's why you ask these questions. So it's good.
Next question. After we turn in a cheek swab, do you muscle tests for a specific brand of a
particular supplement that you are wanting to recommend the answer's yes? So let's say I'm
recommending a specific brand of curcumin, let's pretend. And you may comment back, well I already
have this brand. Can I just take this? I may look at the label and if it's comparable, I may say, yeah,
you can probably take that just fine. But there are some that I would question. So let's finish
a question. I'm asking because I can get some pharmaceutical grade supplements at wholesale and
didn't know if I do it so I could possibly get a brand that was not right for me.
Well, that is true. It may be true, let's say. The thing to do I think is just to send me
those things that I could look at them. There may be some really good supplements. If you could
get a bit wholesale, then I'll say, yeah, I think you could just take that. So, but there may be
something I may say, no. So just ask me those things that would be the best thing to do.
Next question. I'm taking Marina, the brand is Rosa Bella, to help us stress and sleep. They are
800 milligram capsules. The bottle cells not to take more than one a day. I've not seen any differences
yet after a week of taking them. Would it be okay to take a higher dose? Okay, so I looked at that brand
and that I would consider that an off brand. Now, some of the off brand supplements can be just mine
and some of the off brand supplements can be really bad. So, how do you know? Well, you don't.
I do know that there are certain brands that are very anal at testing their raw products. And
thereby I have a lot of confidence in their final outcome. So, that's one thing, especially with
herbs. So, that's what's more difficult to know. So, if it's a mineral or a vitamin, it's easier
to just look at the label. For instance, if I'm looking at a mineral and it says calcium as calcium
carbonyl, well, you should just put that in your garden because nobody should consume that. But if it
said tracks or albion calcium and albaltracks or albion magnesium, regardless if it was an off brand,
they're using good minerals. Go ahead and take that. So, it's easier to look at a label and look at
whether it's a synthetic bee. That's not a good one to take. If it's a whole food bee,
that's a good one to take. And whether it's an albion or a tracks bound mineral, that's a good one to take.
If it's not, if it's a soil-based mineral or something like that, that's a not good one to take. But with
herbs, it's more difficult because the labels can be very misleading. It can have very beautiful
colorful label because they did a wonderful job marketing. But there can be almost none of the product
in there. And this was tested about, I don't know, maybe eight years ago, independent lab ran tests
on different herbs. I've talked about this before. They found that some of them literally had
none in the capsule, none of the herb that it was talked about in the capsule. So that's where you have
to be careful with the brand that you're using. So I can't vouch for this Roosevelt brand.
But let's say they are 800 milligrams in those capsules or let's say it's 800 milligrams in two
capsules and they're recommending two capsules a day. And it says don't take more than that because
they're just trying to, lots of times they'll say don't take more than, they're just trying to protect
themselves. They want you to talk to somebody. They're not a, they're not your physician, right? So
they want you to, you know, definitely, no one's ever going to get hurt with taking 800 milligrams of
Moringa. However, there's good reputable brands that I would say that
have more than that in it and recommend three times that dose even on their label. So
there really isn't a dangerous dose of Moringa. Though I would say like any herb Moringa is one
that could be tainted, could be dirty. A lot of the herbs have a lot of heavy metals and toxins
and pesticides and herbicides. So by, you want to try to stay to organic herbs, I don't know
that brand. But in general, if it was a good, clean organic brand, no, you could take more.
A question from the chat. What is your favorite methyl B12 for someone with high hobosistine?
Now the reason that person asked that question is that I typically don't recommend methyl,
methylated vitamins, methylated B12, methylated folic acid folate, with somebody with cancer
because methyl groups can turn off tumor suppressor genes and can cause the cancer to grow. But if a
person, the caveat to that is if a person has high hobosistine. So if a person has high hobosistine,
they need to take methyl B12 or methyl folate. So what's the good brand? Well, this is one of those.
Going back to the question I just spoke about. About how do you know if you have a good supplement
or a bad supplement. Well, if it's methyl, cobalamide, their methyl cobalamide is methyl cobalamide. So it
doesn't really make any difference when brand you're getting it from. If it's the methylated folate,
it's methyl tetrahedral folate. You'll see that as, if I'd say, if I'd even say folic acid, which is,
which folic acid is a synthetic folate. So you would never, nobody should take folic acid.
But still some good companies still list something as folic acid because they know that the general
population is too ignorant to know what folate is. So they still list the old name folic acid. But
then it may say folic acid as methyl tetrahedral folate. Okay, so that's the good source of folate.
But usually it should properly be labeled folate as methyl tetrahedral folate. So that would be the
correct form of folate and the correct form of B12. If a person as high homocysteine is taking
methyl tetrahedral folate and methyl cobalamide, brand really doesn't matter with that.
Next question from the chat. Would you recommend for those nights when you just can't get to sleep
or feel like I'm really in a deep sleep? What would you recommend if you can't get to sleep
or you can't get to do a deep sleep? Well, if you can't fall asleep, then you start thinking that it's,
you could have melatonin issues, taking melatonin, taking some things that will call your brain.
Many times we can't fall asleep because our brain is too revved up. It's actually fired at a
frequency that's a high beta wave. So normally if you're wide awake and you're focused in your
elicity, like everybody's doing right now, your brain is in a beta wave. Or if I bore you to death,
your brain is in an alpha wave and you're just about ready to fall asleep. That's probably most
people listening to me right now. But that's what you want to get your brain down to in order to fall asleep.
So maybe you should just listen to some videos of mine and then we'll get your brain into an alpha sleep
and you'll just fall right asleep. Thank you Dr. Cutters. You're such a help. You helped me fall
asleep every night. Well, I'm hopefully getting, but maybe no. Getting your brain to an alpha wave
is important. And one of the things that hinders that is watching TV, watching screen time,
looking at your computer, looking at your phone. All screens, all computer screens, all television screens,
your phone screen is, is firing at a frequency of 60 hertz. So you're actually in what's called
in training your brain at 60 hertz. What a high beta wave is about 30, 35 hertz, you're firing your
brain at 60 hertz. It can be difficult for you to fall asleep at night because your brain is in this
high hertz dopamine reaction. So you can't get to sleep. There's other things that have to do with
your own transmitters because you're actually firing more glutamate as a glutamate as a newer transmitter.
So it gets your brain fired up and you're thinking of all the things that you need to do tomorrow.
That's because of brain and treatment as well, at least to place a part of that. So try to take some
herbs that will help calm down your brain, can be helpful, magnesium, L-theonate. We have
product called insomnetol that has some calming herbs, different adaptogens, can be calming,
melatonin can be helpful. If you wake up at night, you can't fall back asleep. That can be because of
a cortisol issue, actually, too low of cortisol. So you might be burning the candle at two ends
during the day. You're burning out your adredals and you have two low of a cortisol output in the
middle of the night. That's what has to keep you asleep. You need a good healthy cortisol output
in the middle of the night to stimulate a breakdown of glycogen in your liver in order to feed your
brain so that your brain has enough glucose. So your brain's trying to wake you up and get you to
walk around in the middle of the night so that you'll start to create glucose through glucose
genesis with the breakdown of muscle. That's the only way you can do it. So that can be an issue.
It can be because of lack of protein intake. That can be an issue. So make sure you're eating some
maybe some chicken before you're going to bed. That might be helpful. So things like that,
the things that you want to look at. I do have several blog posts and videos on this, too,
that might be helpful. Next question. I have normal blood pressure, but my heart rate is higher
than normal. Sometimes I'm sitting at it is a hundred or more. Why could this be happening?
Well, if you have normal blood pressure, but your heart rate is higher than normal, there could be
several possibilities. If you look at your latest blood work and you look at your vitamin D levels,
I'd be interested to see that because what are the things that you think are the first thing that
you think of with elevated heart rate with normal blood pressure is a vitamin D deficiency.
It's a very common with people with a VAQ gene defect. So having a deficiency in vitamin D,
which I would say anything lower than 60 to maybe 80 would be too low of vitamin D and could cause
heart rate increase. There's other reasons for heart rate increase, too. You could have some
calcification, some of your neurological communication to your heart. So you have
stimulants in your brain and in your chronic arteries that stimulate and balance heart rate.
Also, heart rate is controlled by the sympathetic nervous system. So different
amounts of stress can increase heart rate. So if you have an elevated heart rate,
while you're just sitting there and calm as a cucumber, and there's just no way I have any stress
in my life right now, I'm just calm as a cucumber and my heart is elevated. It can be due to some
different nutritional things, too. So I think first vitamin D can be some, there can be some
even things like food sensitivities or something like that that can stimulate
sympathetic response. If you go to our blog again and you search sympathetic or parasympathetic,
you'll see a video, a blog post, and a video describing the difference between sympathetic and parasympathetic.
And you'll see exercises that you can look at that can help calm your sympathetic and another
sheet of exercise in these are PDFs that you can download, ways to calm your parasympathetics or
distillate your parasympathetics. So that's the things that you'd want to look at. What I used to
do a lot of functional neurology, we'd have similar questions to this where people didn't have cancer,
but they had heart rate variability issues. Call me, their sympathetic was the key,
then hyperactive sympathetic. So there's neurological exam where you could actually test for this,
but you'd have to be in person and I'd have to test you neurologically. But that is a common issue,
is that an increased sympathetic tone. So you might feel calm as a cucumber, but your sympathetic
nervous system isn't hyper-drive. Give me an example about this, here's another Instagram
video that I just saw the other day that said, nobody should be wearing sunglasses. Some glasses
are bad for you. That sunglasses actually cause skin cancer. That's what the person did and there
was a clip from a podcast where a person was saying sunglasses cause skin cancer. Then the reason was
part of what he said was true. Sunlight on your retina stimulates your body to release this certain
enzyme that is beneficial for your skin. Well, that is true, but excess sunlight on your retina. How
much of that do you need to help with releasing that enzyme? Excess sunlight, especially with somebody
who has had a lot of stress in their life, which you could probably list every person as an adult
in that category, excess sunlight will stimulate your sympathetic nervous system. It has purposes
to stimulate your sympathetic. However, we already have an increased sympathetic nervous system.
There's some people are prone to because of certain neurological issues in excess hyper-tonic
sympathetic nervous system. An excess hyper-tonic sympathetic nervous system is going to cause
deficiency or a lower parasympathetic. They go in a balance like a teeter-tonner. If you have
a hyper-sympathetic, you're going to have hypo-parasympathetics. When you have hypo-parasympathetics,
you're going to have a decrease immune function, increase risk of cancer, you're going to have a decrease
detoxification ability because it's all controlled by your parasympathetics. You're going to have
the hyper-stimulation of the sympathetic is going to cause an increased heart rate, can cause
high blood pressure, but that could be spared. An increased rate of all causes morbidity because it's
going to, you're not supposed to be in a hyper-sympathetic state. Your sympathetic nervous system is
for fight-and-flight immediate response to help you through an immediate crisis. It's not meant to
live there. So when we live in a hyper-sympathetic state, we end up with sympathetic overdrive
disorders. And heart rate is going to be one of those casualties. So look at that. And I will say that
wearing sunglasses, going back to that example, help calm your sympathetic direct sunlight to your
retinas, though it does stimulate that enzyme that can be good for your skin also stimulates
your sympathetic. So while I don't think you should wear sunglasses 99% of the time, even if you
wore sunglasses that were that blocked 50% of the sunlight and you're out of the sun, you're still
getting enough to stimulate those enzyme production while you're still calming your brain to not
put you in a sympathetic overdrive or to help prevent that. So again, another
I watch Instagram videos just like you do. And I get mad because it's like this is just
wrong information. At least we need a balanced comment here. So and so that means I have to be careful
watch your watch. Lugs answer it for how do I decrease and how do I know what's causing my heart
right increase. Could be neurological and the neurological component is going to be sympathetic.
Could be food driven. Could be you know just stress driven which is going to be sympathetic also.
So look at that video and download those sheets and start doing some of the exercise that will
call be your sympathetic your sympathetic are housed in the part of the brain called the mesencephalon.
So that sheet I think says mesencephalon. Mesencephalic call be nexercises and then your
parasympathetics are housed in the vagal nerve. So the other one I think says vagal nerve stimulating.
Maybe it says parasympathetic stimulating exercise. So download both of them. They're different
little different exercises. Some of them seem silly but they actually do work. Hopefully that helps
any other questions. Okay with that I think we will say goodbye now that we're praying for you
and we hope you're praying for us and for others. I think that's what our greatest purpose is
to glorify God. All right. Bye-bye.